Trong cuộc phòng bần với New York Times,
tổng thống thống mì đồn anh trọng em tảm ổn đền ngọt cả năng,
Washington, Sae Zam Sa, và Kim Phvat 1.000 mỏ của bình như vậy là
trong rất nhiều năm sau chuyến dịch quan sự bắt giữ tổng thống
nịch glass mà đưa hồ không một bắt thống ổn trọng cuộc khẳng định
Mỹ sẽ tảyết với như vậy là theo các dất có lời
sự dụng và Kim Phvat 2 mỏ của nước này để kéo ra dấu xuống,
lòng thời cùng tất mồn tại chính Mac Carcass,
lất gần trong cuộc phòng bần ông trọng phòng phòng viên,
Washington đang hợp tắc rất tốt với chính cố của tổng thống
lâm thời đe Xe Rồi Gess, và nói ngoại trường Mac Công Bío
thường xuyên lên là khối bà Rồi Gess, khi được phòng viên họ
ở vý sao không học thận phản đối lập với như vậy là
dành chính quyền sau khi loại bỏ tổng thống mà đưa ổn trọng trọng trà lời,
về việc với như vậy là tổng thống lâm thời đe Xe Rồi Gess trước
đó muốn ngày công buồn bà đình hộ chí chi trên trốt,
để điều hành đến nước trong buổi cạnh mấy,
đồ tiến mặt khẳng định tư tiến hàng đầu là khối thương
thống thống niệm của lác mà đưa ổn cung phương nhân
thứ hai là đàn bảo hòa biên trên tròn anh hổ,
dưa bự chất tự và ordic để đánh nước bự qua ra đỏ thổ căn
và khuy công là tập trung vào việc duy trì khả năng khoả trị chính trị của
nhà nước thông qua thùng bố sĩ đỏ két quả của bự cơm lập.